we are indeed with another victor of
today's round that is talia
cervantestalia welcome back to the
studio welcome back to the u.s junior
girls championship how did you train for
this event in particular well um thank
you so much this is my last year so i am
hoping all fingers crossed that things
go well and i can end my my run in this
tournament with a good streak
um i was just doing preparation just as
much as i could and tried to stay active
i didn't play any tournaments since the
summer started so i played a lot of
training games and i was actually more
doing summer camp jobs
rather than than actually playing which
might be a mistake but um yeah it's been
fun and i i try my best to kind of get a
hint of
how to prepare it but obviously
everything's determined yesterday right
with the drawing of lot so but you also
played some rapid saturday night uh
events here in saint louis that gave you
tremendous preparation for sure yeah i
miss that so much i haven't played the
saturday night specials and like some
tournaments here at the chess club and
it's always nice to play and you get to
see friends and
obviously try and make some money too so
yeah it's been nice now a great start
for you with the black pieces how did
you approach this game did you want it
given that she's a newcomer to the event
did you want to put some pressure early
on with the black pieces um i did that
was my main reason why i did a um
exchange sacrifice
here at the
uh
in the opening very nice right i'm not
exactly sure about the evaluation uh the
move order that she played i didn't
prepare for but i thought that i'm
taking away two of the main things
or the biggest things i guess in her
position right the center and the light
square bishop so i imagine you know
maybe if it wasn't clear i would still
have some
some more comfortable play maybe i
played it a little bit too slow i felt
like um i shouldn't have allowed this
knight d2
f394 type of ideas maybe i should have
played like queen iaid
sooner
um
yeah so uh originally i didn't want to
trade knights on d5 because the knight
on c3
if you look at it like a few months ago
it has no future and it could block any
any activity on on the c file
so
i i didn't feel comfortable trading it
and i spent a lot of time in that move
but i at the same time had no idea what
to do because the knight is coming to e4
but eventually things kind of came
together i was really happy with this f5
i thought that
maybe now i have some chances right like
my main idea is g5 and f4 and i'm also
controlling the e4 squaria so
um
yeah here at h4
i i felt like it wasn't the best but i
wasn't sure what the boss was
a move at this point instead of h4
i was concerned like b1 or knight f1 the
thing is that with knight f1 it doesn't
i don't know where the future is for the
night because an e3 doesn't
do that much either i can always put
division you can stop it with g5 f4
right right so
i thought that if she wanted to find
some play for her pieces he would have
to maneuver around
but i mean that's on her end too so she
needs to find it
um
right i wasn't sure if this was the best
continuation but at least i went upon so
that is something well yeah it's all
smiles yeah that's brilliant that's
really
um yeah but i think on the time travel
is when the main things happen maybe i
could have played better too but it
almost felt like it does feel like
you're
and you finished quite swiftly and
nicely as well with this queen to be one
rook to c8
and uh this uh queen to g1
at the end a big victory for you a nice
start uh who do you have tomorrow
i think i have jennifer i got number six
so i'm repeating black oh that's that's
a big game with the black pieces against
the rating favorite have you ever uh met
her in uh right yeah
we have played three
classical games i think and we have one
and a half to one and a half so that's
going to be fun to play her again i
haven't played her in a really long time
so very contested
big collegiate uh battle she is
attending harvard you're attending st
louis university good luck tomorrow
thank you thank you well done tell you
we we liked the finish very much we were
all like pom-poms and cheerleading at
your success very very nice uh
finish there we liked it very very much